schnitte formen materialien saison für
saison neu der letzte schrei plastik aus
meeres müll
adidas beispielsweise sorgt mit einem
turnschuh für schlagzeilen
gefertigt aus herrenlosen fischernetz
immer häufiger setzen mode designer und
labels aus rezyklierten ozean abfall
mehr und mehr auch prominente popstar
stilikone pharrell williams entwirft
kollektionen für die star die kampagne
rolf radespiel mensch und umwelt happy
macht
diester und adidas ins boot geholt hat
aber dieser mann serie guter deutscher
designer und marken strategie die new
york hat er die meeresschutzorganisation
pauli vor die oceans gegründet der
clevere netzwerker versammelt um sich
künstler wissenschaftler politiker
aktivisten sein ziel
aufsehen erregen öffentlichkeit spielt
eine große rolle in unserem programm
und ja wir kreieren einen trend hier
und warum die menschen mitmachen darum
diese persönlichkeiten unterstützen das
sei nicht ganz einfach
wir haben die verantwortung als kreative
wir steuern viel mehr als uns jeden tag
bewusst ist dass einmal klar wird was
von einfluss wir haben als entwickler
aber auch als celebrity dann müssen wir
diesen einfluss einfach dazu nutzen
veränderungen bei zu führen und eine
gute idee hat keinen besitzer klingt
generös und vielversprechend rund 25
prozent recycling plastik werden ins
gewebe für die kleider eingearbeitet
doch eine ökobilanz fehlt
über das desaster in den meeren hingegen
liegen zahlen vor
experten schätzen dass pro stunde weit
über 1000 tonnen plastikmüll in den
ozeanen lautet eine der folgen unzählige
tiere verenden qualvoll
die schockierenden bilder aus dem
dokumentarfilm midway sprechen eine
deutliche sprache
kein zweifel
dagegen muss etwas getan werden doch ist
mode mit recyceltem plastik das
geeignete mittel dazu aufmerksamkeit
lenken worauf auf die misere oder die
marke die sich mit umweltschutz brüstet
und wird ja nicht suggeriert auf der
perfekten welle zu reiten
für christian brändle direktor des
museums für gestaltung in zürich hat die
rettung der ozeane seite ausstellung
endstation mehr die noch immer um die
welt tourt wenig mit happy zu tun
prominenz hin oder her aber das ist
nicht das ist wie wenn die ganze stadt
brennt und sie offerierten grill zum
wüste leute interessieren
mehr als 13 millionen tonnen neuer
plastikmüll jährlich die in der mode
verwendete menge ist derzeit europa
tisch zu nennen das bestätigt auch siri
coach in diesem jahr werden die
auswirkungen ist sehr groß und klein
groß sollen sie werden die dinge schon
bald die massen erreichen so das
versprechen
trotzdem oder gerade deshalb christian
brändle bleibt skeptisch
gut vorstellen dass ein schluss sogar
screen regeneriert und zeit musste ich
meine crew die hose so lässt brenders
ansatz kein kreatives muss sondern
nüchtern auf die problematik hinweisen
und den irrsinn mit allen mitteln
stoppen
ich glaube nicht daran dass man menschen
was verbieten kann ich glaube daran dass
man inspirieren sollte und was wir tun
es wir inspirieren dazu ein problem hat
eine grosse chance zu sehen dinge anders
zu machen anders ja die frage bleibt sie